it's a small box so it's one of the  deadliest diseases that was affecting  Mankind in the mid 69 1700s Dr Edward  General developed the first ever  vaccination in the world in 1796 and  that was it to combat this deadly  disease small dogs there were some local  rumors that people who get infected by  cowpox are less susceptible to develop  symptoms of smallpox so what uh Janet  did was he inoculated an 80 year old boy  James with with matter from a cowpox  suit right in the initial days he felt  very sick but then he recovered fully  and two months later in July 1796 he  inoculated James Swift once again with  matter from a human smallpox suit and  what ended up happening yes that's right  he was not affected by it at all so the  cure for smallpox was home and the first  cell vaccination was discovered by Dr  John so for more such amazing videos  follow your members